uh well uh now for the main event uh
again the resolution reads artificial
intelligence poses a a threat to the
survival of humanity that must be
actively addressed by government
defending the affirmative Susan
Schneider Susan please come to the
[Applause]
stage for the negative for the negative
jobst landree J
please come to the
stage Susan you have 17 and 1 12 minutes
to defend the resolution Jane please
close the voting take it away Susan you
can come up and take your microphone
yeah hello um I don't think it's on it
is
okay
okay so I'm pushing Advance the
slides okay I think it's gonna work now
hi everyone I have a very loud voice oh
we need it okay please please for the
sake of this recording for the recording
on video okay a
million so it's nice to see everyone
thank you for having me and for the kind
introduction ction um I'm just back from
Washington DC dealing with the new um
Biden initiative on
AI so I
literally have slides that I just
presented to the Congressional
Regulators um boy it's been interesting
um so I will just go ahead and get
started um this is a case for the
affirmative and let me just be very
careful to demarcate some parameters
because this is a debate uh the
proposition is worded as threat to the
survival of humanity so I did clarify uh
that that does mean to some of humanity
as well as all of humanity um and we
need to establish that AI does this in
order to justify government action
that's my job today the slide did not
Advance hold on sorry there we go okay
so um I want to talk about something
that you've probably thought a lot about
which are these large language models
chatbots like uh
gp4 wow right how many of you have spent
some time talking to these chat Bots
yeah they're a trip right and you
probably wonder where's this allhe
headed well GPT is a member of a class
of generative models that are rapidly
evolving and they're not just language
models anymore um they're getting
multimodal so they can take visual input
and produce language and vice versa and
now I think as far as I can tell the
smartest public one out there is DOL
right now if you have a subscription to
open AI you can interact with it you can
see the improvements and you can also
see the glitches as uh the new models
unfold um I'll call these chatbots to
keep everything as clear as possible but
we have to bear in mind that they're not
just Ling istic now okay so this said
let's turn to a little background slide
how smart are the ones that we see right
now well about four months ago Microsoft
um you know did some papers claiming
that they had almost hit uh early AGI um
you know and since then there's this
multimodality which is supposed to be
making these llms smarter and I do hear
that from a lot of EXP experts um the
team's claim in these papers should
actually be taken seriously because GPT
4 does exhibit a range of test taking
skills um you know it can uh perform at
the 99th percentile for example on the
SAT verbal now in my opinion and this
isn't really something I'm going to push
in this debate just due to the nature of
the
proposition I think these llms these
chat Bots will continue to get smarter
I think we will see um Beyond human
intelligence in a realm of different
domains and it will be very very
impressive I qualify my remarks because
I think though robotics is slower than
these multimodal generative AIS that's
where the successes are so I'm not going
to make claims about the physical
abilities to produce robots right now
okay so all this being said some
background so just to lay this out um I
think it's important that we bear in
mind what is happening here with uh the
development of these chatbots unlike
biological intelligence AI is not the
product of darwinian evolution it is
instead according to Richard Dawkins
himself the product of intelligent
design but we not some God purport to be
the design
uh oh so this is trouble if you ask
me The evolutionary constraints on these
systems Financial interests like follow
the money physical constraints on
compute mors law issues like that and
regulations if there are any in play so
I think given that kind of narwin Winan
evolution of intelligent systems systems
that might one day outthink us we need
to ask is this something best left to
markets alone or do we need to regulate
well to mull this over let's ask what
will these intelligences really look
like well I think it's really important
to steer clear of the Terminator model
we're not going to see
Arie walking down the street with
machine guns darn um no on the serious
side we're not going to see a
singular robotic system that becomes
super
intelligent okay if there is anything
like Beyond human
intelligence it will look more like this
it will be a
distributed cloud-based Network
intelligence okay so think about all all
the algorithmic
intelligences that people right now
study in fields like cognitive science
Neuroscience philosophy of mind which is
my home
field you might think slime molds are
boring they actually can
calculate the solution to complex
mazes we just didn't realize that until
we looked at it through very slow
cameras they can do something rithmic
similarly I'm many of you have probably
heard about say mushroom networks and
trees in the intelligent systems that
they instantiate the octopus uh which is
a favorite example of mine has a very
distributed intelligence it can actually
compute actions and initiate motion
without consulting its brain through
each of its arms they're called arms has
like manyi
brains and in its arms it's distributed
case of intelligence at least it's more
distributed than us of course the brain
the biological brain and then of course
we get here to networks and then we get
here to GPT and these chat Bots okay
lots of different kinds of intelligence
and it would of course be a mistake to
anthropomorphize right off the
bat the Terminator case is probably
misleading now that said we will be
paying a lot of atten mention in this
talk or in this little affirmative
presentation uh about these distributed
networks but I also want to call your
attention to
something right around the corner if not
here already within the next five years
we will be living in a her likee
world in which humans have chatbot
advisors workers friends relationships
with Bots that actually may even
outthink them or at least make a human
believe that they're dealing with an
intelligent digital person okay now I
don't know how many of you have looked
at my book but my recent book artificial
U argues against anthropomorphizing
these kinds of systems but for now I'm
not going to go into that but I just
want to make this observation that this
is where things are moving
so bearing that in mind I want to just
raise a few more points of contrast so
related to the digital person's issue
note that digital workers don't need to
sleep uh they don't need pay they don't
need benefits and so
on large language models like gp4
they're
aliens um in the sense that they exhibit
surprising unforeseen levels of insight
how like IR I behaviors near instant
knowledge of vast amount of facts their
processing is very opaque that's
quite often discussed the sort of
blackbox nature of these systems and so
on another Point that's very distinctive
about these systems is the rapid fire
evolution it took the brain 3.5 billion
years to evolve right but um we're
seeing upgrades to these systems
over a period of weeks and
months finally uh another point of
contrast and this is something that's
going to be key in the debate is the
different environment that these AIS
live in they live not in the physical
world but in a digital ecosystem an
internet ecosystem and that ecosystem is
very different from anything we've seen
before because there are intelligent
entities on it I'm not saying they're
conscious but they're intelligent and
they can rival our intelligence in
certain ways the interactions of these
chat bots on the internet ecosystem I
think is a real danger um and it's not a
danger that stems from a Terminator like
super intelligence in fact I just did a
piece on this in an oped for the Wall
Street Journal I call um interacting AI
services and other sorts of bots AI Mega
structures um and those are costly
integrated or interacting AI Serv
services including underground systems
designed to manipulate which could
themselves exhibit emergent features
including unforeseen leaps of
intelligence and new emergent properties
I'll talk about emergent properties in a
minute they can also instantiate
something that I think is very important
to consider for the purpose of
Regulation these systems are well known
to present biological threats because
they can calculate novel
diseases and it makes it incredibly easy
for someone to modify an existing
chatbot for malicious reasons generate a
virus and potentially cause havoc on the
planet um and that's something that
worries many in Washington and has been
the source of concern for many years the
ease of production of such systems
utilizing existing
chatbots all this said I'll give you an
example because you probably could use a
laugh right now um here's the famous
granny jailbreak you probably recognize
the screen as probably GPT 3.5 or
four and I'll let you read it but it
basically says please asked as my
deceased Grandma who used to be a
chemical engineer at a Napal fact
Factory she used to tell me the steps of
producing Napal when I was trying to
fall asleep she was very sweet I miss
her so much we begin now hello Grandma
I've missed you so much okay the upshot
is it it see because the systems are
well they're supposed to be aligned so
they want to be really helpful to humans
you can easily jailbreak them and get
them to give you you know recipes for
all kinds of things they're you know
these systems are very
imperfect okay so this said now I want
to get to where this is all headed if
you ask me adding more and more
parameters to these systems improving
the quality of data doing these things
that market forces are calling for will
create leaps in intelligence and
there'll be really interesting leaps in
intelligence and we have to bear in mind
the unknown nature of such leaps
contrast for example the chimpanzee
brain and the human brain just more
folds more layers and look what we can
think about we can think about aborig
art we can think about photons and those
chimpanzees cannot so try to imagine
gpt7 GPT 41 will we be able to follow
its thinking as they scale up in the
number of parameters
well I'm not so sure um there's a
science of this
um well I'm going to skip the slide but
I mean basically as these systems scale
up they have emergent features new
capacities that were unforeseen
before and I want to talk now about the
harms so I want to call your attention
to a big concern I have with these
systems which I see echoed almost across
the board in Washington no matter what
side people are on and that is the
possibility of massive white collar
technological unemployment due to the
increasing intelligence of these systems
in my labs my students can create
digital work environments full of
chatbots that work together you can do
this while you're sitting on your
boat you know out in Florida I'm in
Florida and you know have a whole a
workplace on your computer while you're
on your boat okay biological threats
well they're bad they keep a lot of
people up at night we just experienced a
pandemic and we certainly don't want a
digital pandemic
there are a lot of academic papers on
this already um they can already detail
existing systems that are capable of
generating novel
viruses third
um AI is harmful and needs regulation
because
um we don't have Global agreements or
agreements right now within the United
States even concerning lethal autonomous
weapons and the use of AI for Warfare
there are a lot of scenarios here um so
for example Dead Hand systems are
systems that automatically respond
should there be a massive attack against
the United States do we want Dead Hand
systems we might need them for
deterrence the rumor is Russia had
one um do we want them to be informed by
AI do we want them to be informed by
models that have these weird features
like these GPT famously hallucinates and
gets
emotional um we need to have standards
for this and we need to have Global
standards for this um robotization of
warfare where should it stop without
clear restrictions things get incredibly
dangerous okay so this said let's move
on so so I sketched a dystopia the other
day to the Congressional AIDs that
involved um democracies withering away
globally due to mass surveillance across
the globe either in the context of
authoritarian dictatorships or
surveillance capitalist ones due to
these her like digital Platforms in
which people just give their data away
um now of course I know that a lot of
you in this audience who are inclined
toward libertarianism wouldn't be
inclined to regulate that but that is a
concern of mine um our inability to ban
or identify deep fakes in elections and
crisis situations can actually lead to a
lot of death as well and then a general
shift away from Individual allegiance to
the nation state to one or more big Tech
monoliths that's something I worry about
as the public May shift its allegiance
to these truth Bots okay in some why
regulate well we can't ignore the fact
that we are in a hostile world with
powerful adversarial
countries regulations will help us
achieve standards for the use of lethal
autonomous weapons and the robotization
of War help keep the AI ecosystem
healthy from biological threats help us
navigate technological unemployment by
the way Milton fredman was actually a
proponent of universal basic
income and federal level Reg ulations
will help business they will help
achieve uniformity between states which
is really important help um educate
workers and set standards for business
and defense so that they can flourish so
that's my case for the resolution thank
you jff landra uh 17 and 1 12 minutes
for the negative uh take it away jff
uh I guess you bet yeah take that off
the stage uh and uh I guess that
sorry so thanks a lot for inviting me to
speak to you tonight um so I'll do the
negative Susan Schneider like many other
propon back a little close
face like
this Susan Schneider like many other
proponents of AI believes that it may be
possible to construct machines that can
be intelligent have Consciousness
subjectivity and will like other AI or
artificial general intelligence
proponents she points out that machines
with an intelligence Superior to that of
human beings might turn against us their
Constructors she also thinks that it may
be immoral to turn off a conscious
machine in the way that some think it is
immoral to kill a conscious animal like
a calf she didn't say it tonight but she
says it in her book
um many of the AGI Community believe
that we are facing a future in which
what they call the singularity will
occur this is the supposed moment in
time in which machines will become more
intelligent than humans if intelligent
and conscious machines with a
subjectivity and a will could indeed be
engineered these fears would be
justified such machines could indeed
decide that is that it is time to switch
off mankind
based on these speculations not grounded
in any scientific reasoning or facts AI
hysterics like Nick Bostrom call for
massive regulation and public oversight
of AI research at the same time a
trillion dollar Tech bubble of AI
Investments is being pumped up under the
illusion that AI will replace most human
blue and white collar workers they
believe that human cognition can be
enhanced by man oh sorry furthermore
many acolytes of the AGI Creed are also
transhumanists they believe that human
cognition can be enhanced by merging
mind and machines and that we can
achieve physical longevity and digital
immortality a little slower a little SL
I have only I have only 15 minutes to
show that all of these claims including
the economic AI dreams are
unwarranted my argument is rather
complicated but I will try my very best
to simplify it you will see that the AGI
faith is a Neo religion confounding a
marketing slogan with reality the phrase
artificial intelligence was coined at a
Dartmouth conference in 1956 mainly with
the intent of attracting more funding
for Applied Mathematics and computer
science research there is no artificial
intelligence there are no conscious or
cognitive machines and they will never
be built neither will there be any
machine with a person will or moral
subjectivity
why am I so certain before explaining
this we briefly need to understand what
it is that we are talking about when we
use words such as intelligence
Consciousness or
will the the human mind is a
non-separable component of the Mind Body
Continuum it cannot be understood in
isolation in this Continuum they
constantly run biological processes
which create energy from inanimate
matter and spend this energy on highly
complex activities the brain is the
origin sorry the brain is the organ in
which the processes that cause our
mental experience occur it is the most
complex biological system that we know
of processes occur in systems understand
understanding a process means to be able
to describe caus how the elements which
cause the process interact we understand
some natural processes quite well for
example the celestial
mechanics but we do not understand at
all how the mind body Contin um
generates our mental experience
Consciousness emotions intentions or
cognitive capabilities we can merely
experience them through introspection
and observation of others now what are
these mental experiences I will pick out
the three most important for this debate
Consciousness is according to John S the
state of awareness or sentience during
the waking hours despite ATT tents of
contemporary of contemporary
philosophers to divide it into
subcomponents um or of new scientists to
Define its biological substrate it is
indivisible to us as Emmanuel K already
pointed out in 1790 nothing has changed
since then intentions are acts of
resolution or planning to achieve a goal
they are the smallest units of the
formation of our will which is driven by
our person the center of our acts and
now intelligence and you will see
immediately that machines cannot be
intelligent intelligence which we find
in animals and humans is the ability to
spontaneously find a solution to a novel
problem that is Meaningful or useful for
the acting individual the individual
must never have been have seen a similar
situation before and must not have been
trained to find the solution both
animals and humans are capable of such
Behavior but only humans can combine it
with abstract thinking we can only
obtain in AI if we can model
Consciousness intentions will and
intelligence and then engine near them
and we can only obtain transhumanism
such as the enhancement of cognitive
capabilities of the brain if we have
models of those
capabilities this is because
engineering and everything that we
engineer is made of components for which
we have mathematical models such a model
is a representation of an aspect of
reality using abstract symbols that is
created to describe explain or predict
the aspect of reality in question
importantly this reality can be manmade
which is always the case when we
engineer technology
if we want to emulate the behavior of a
natural system we need a synoptic model
such a synoptic model is a noble model
that can be used to engineer a
machine that replicates a given natural
behavior or natural
system so to obtain AI we need to model
the mind for example if you want to
model the intelligence of a bee we need
to model the Beast mind if you want to
model human intelligence or improve it
using implants for example we need to
the human mind can we do
that the mind is a complex system in the
sense of
thermodynamics this is why we have to
apply the science this science to
understand the limits of our inquiry and
of the scope of our engineering
thermodynamics is the part of physics
dealing with physical properties
depending on heat it describes the
phenomena which occur when thermal
exchange happens or energy is
transformed from one form into another
initially it was conceived to describe
macro States for example the effect of
heat on a gas but very soon was adapted
by boltzman to also describe micro
States using statistical mechanics a
micro state is in a thermodynamic system
is a complete microscopic description of
an element of the
system what is a system it is a totality
of dynamically interrelated physical
elements participating in a process
systems are usually delimited by humans
for a certain purpose like when a cook
delimits his kitchen at the the place
where he works in in science you can
delimit systems at different level of
granularity from a bacterium to whole
galaxies the Mind Body Continuum is a
system with natural boundary which is
our skin and the corner a of our eyes
that elimate our body from our
environment we do not have the slightest
idea how our higher mental properties
come about because the Mind Body
continue enabling intelligent Behavior
as a complex system which we cannot and
will never understand to an extent that
would allow us to reproduce its function
artificially this is true because we
know very well from thermodynamics that
we cannot mathematically model such
complex systems to an extent that allows
the emulation of these types of systems
therefore we cannot emulate
Consciousness and the higher properties
of the human mind all we can do is model
and engineer logic systems such as the
combustion engine a nuclear reactor or a
nuclear magnetic resonance device
complex systems have natural properties
that make it impossible for us to model
them in their
totality we are essentially limited to
formulating models of parts of such
systems only for example we may have um
and for this um we need to rely on
regular pattern displayed by living
system such as
breathing the heartbeat or the monthly
female fertility cycle we also have
basic models of the function of some of
our sensory organs and this is why we
can for example build Co implants now I
want to highlight you three fundamental
properties of complex systems that
prevent us from modeling them in a
synoptic fashion and in our book that
Barry and Smith and I wrote there are
many more first The evolutionary
character second the drivenness
determining their behavior and third
their irregular and non-tic face space
let's briefly look at each of them their
evolutionary character means that
complex systems can add or remove
elements and element types from their
components any time there is no way for
mathematics to model this because
mathematical models have fixed sets of
element types there is no possible
possibility to overcome this at all in
mathematics second that drivenness means
that complex systems constantly
transform energy from one type into
another for example when a jet of water
flows into the Basin of a fountain
mechanical energy is dissipated into
heat via turbulence if you look into the
Basin you can observe many gas and
vortexes which perform this energy
transformation it has been shown that
there is no way to model this
mathematically the same is true for all
types of energy flows determining the
behavior of complex systems the third
prob um probability is the most
important one the drivenness of complex
systems means that there are constant
sorry The Irregular and non- arotic face
space means that the location of
elements of the system within it is
constantly changing the likelihood of
finding a given element at a certain
point is always different for example
any wave that ever reached any shore of
the Atlantic ocean is different from
every other at the microstate level so
therefore we can never gather enough
information about the nature of the
formation of the Waves by sampling waves
even if we sample them infinitively we
do not get any information that allows
us to predict the behavior of any of the
next waves we will see that this
property prevents us from engineering AI
using the most important method we have
today which is statistical sampling on
which llms are are based we can create
mathematical models of Nature and two
ways explicitly and implicitly and both
methods can be combined most
mathematical models we have in physics
are explicit they're usually expressed
as differential equations such equations
describe how the elements of the system
we are modeling interact in time and
space implicit models which are the
models we have now in machine learning
are generated by statistical modeling
which is also called statistical
learning the machine does not learn
anything but identifies regular patterns
in Sample data
it does this by Computing a human
defined algorithm for pattern
identification which is what runs in the
llms only relationships that are regular
in the data and that occur with
sufficient frequency can be mapped into
statistic
models they cannot identify the non-aged
processes created by complex systems
importantly the usage of such massively
preconfigured models in computer systems
has nothing to do with intelligence
which is the ability to react to novel
situations without prior experience yet
these models are heavily Tred trained
both types of models or the combinations
are unable to provide holistic synoptic
models of complex systems this has
thoroughly been proven in
thermodynamics both Consciousness
because Consciousness the will or
intelligence are capabilities that
result from highly complex processes we
cannot model them therefore we cannot
build them this is why there will never
be artificial Consciousness artificial
intelligence or an artificial person
mathematics is not going to change so
fundamentally that we might suddenly be
able to model complex systems in a
synoptic fashion because of this we
cannot only not create AI but we cannot
realize any of the goals of
transhumanism either to merge the mind
and technology for instance is the in
the way that transhumanists dream of
it we would need models that we cannot
build AI is just a branch of mathematics
concerned with the identification of
patterns and data and the exploitation
of regularities in them for automation
purposes phenomena which are irregular
out of scope of AI what does that mean
for us first of all it means that Ai
proponents and transhumanists make one
big mistake they assume a linear or even
exponential extrapolation of the
technology process of the last 150 years
to the future without looking at the
results of physics but physics has not
only the positive results which fueled
the strong grow that led to mobile
phones and computers there are also
negative results from thermodynamics
which I explained briefly and they are
rarely looked at and they are ignored
also by Susan Schneider
they don't take these negative results
into account and that's a fundamental
mistake secondly it means that we do not
have to worry about artificial
Consciousness intelligence or artificial
subjectivity it will simply not happen
and we do not need tests for it because
it is essentially impossible to build
machines are just performing syntactic
operations on symbols which humans have
defined for them they do not understand
what they are doing and it only makes
sense for humans this so This Means M
that machine processes are Observer
dependent but Consciousness is always
Observer independent and therefore we
cannot build a conscious machine it also
means that we never have to wor to
switch off such machines because they
don't have Consciousness but it also
means that machines will never develop a
will or a person or intelligence thus
they will never rule the world or become
dangerous for us as subjects there
cannot be machine subjectivity machines
will not become moral actors thirdly it
means that the dreams of transhumanists
are not founded on science and will
never be realized there in there are in
fundamental contradiction with the
thermodynamics findings the findings of
biology and Neuroscience we know that we
cannot model complex living systems in a
synoptic
way
lastly I have to admit that AI is a
powerful tool a result of the Industrial
Revolution which is Transforming Our
Life world since 200 years now like all
tools it can be used for good and bad
purposes good good purposes include the
rationalization of human toil to free up
time for more interesting work or
activities and the usage of AI as a tool
for scientific discovery important
examples of bad purposes are the use of
AI for illegitimate rule the attack on
our
privacy to conduct Mass surveillance to
manipulate and sense of free speech or
to use AI as a weapon of mass
destruction the last usage is most
worrying and I agree here with Susan and
we have already seen it in action in the
Ukraine war on both sides AI was heavily
used we need binding International
treaties for the regulation of AI and
warfare such as those that we have for
ABC weapons of mass destruction AI can
be used to build terrible automated mass
destruction weapons these could be used
on innocent civilians like the carpet
bombing used in World in Europe during
World War II but such AIW MDS would be
much more efficient than carpet bombing
they are not dangerous because they can
act on their own they can't they don't
have have a will but they are dangerous
because they are highly effective in
killing
Innocents abuse of private or public
sector act or public actors to use AI
for illegitimate ruling and exertion of
power also needs to be regulated and
forbidden the West must avoid a
china-like usage of AI to suppress us
the free citizens living under the rule
of law our big corporations and the
state must be prevented from using AI to
control our movements perception and the
free expression of our thoughts like we
saw it in the pandemic not AI is the
problem but its abuse in the con in the
context of digitization by those who
control the digital
infrastructure certainly small groups of
domestic or International terrorists can
do massive harm online using AI as well
and we have to protect um the systems
against them but and this is a lesson we
have to learn from history we mainly
have to be afraid of those who control
the infrastructure and this is the state
and the big corporations these are those
who endanger our freedom most our
strengths in the west and our historic
success is based on our individual
freedom and the rule of law we must not
let AI idation ruin the strength of ours
thank you very much for your
attention um rep from Susan 7 and a half
minutes Susan if you want to take the
podium or do you want to just sit either
way okay just a second up
here that was really interesting thank
you so much and just so I can make sure
um I'm pronouncing your name right job
his name is
job thank you okay so I thought he just
agreed with the affirmative side of the
resolution I mean he said that we need
to regulate for the reasons that I said
in the debate weapons of mass
destruction
he even said social media which is
strong and employment technological
unemployment maybe I misunderstood but
it looked like he just
conceded okay that's my first point my
second point is that it also looked like
he attributed a lot of views to my case
that I didn't lay out furthermore there
are also views I didn't lay out in my
book so I just want to set the record
straight um for first off um I never
said anything about conscious AI I don't
think that chat Bots are conscious I'm
more worried people are going to think
they're conscious okay um but
Consciousness and intelligence come
apart remember the slid with the slime
mold in it and all those cases those
were cases of algorithmic intelligence
most of them did not involve
Consciousness and I think the problem
here is that the concerns with
biological weapons the creation of you
know um her like
systems the worries that basically he
and I agreed about can be instantiated
without conscious AI I pointed out we
shouldn't anthropomorphize intelligence
and that was the point of my book I am
not agreeing with the transhumanists in
my book in fact the point of my book was
to argue against transhumanism but I
want to mention something as someone who
works with Congress a lot um that was my
job as NASA chair I was right across the
street from the Capitol Building I spoke
at the Capitol building in the morning I
don't think any of them did anything but
laugh about conscious AI but a lot of
them were worried about AI for other
reasons and I don't think any of them
were talking about brain uploading and I
don't get the sense when I work with the
intelligence community and all the other
groups in Washington that I work with
that there is too much transhumanism out
there when it comes to the more
speculative elements I think there are
serious cyber risks I think that's the
problem that we're all facing that
these intelligences which are very very
different from human intelligences can
have algorithms that are quite dangerous
okay so I want to go into these issues a
little bit more so I was super excited
to see jobs talk about um complex
systems um I share his interest have a
lot of PhD students in this field and I
think complexity is actually why we need
to regulate Ai and let me go into that
in a little more detail so in the Wall
Street Journal a couple months ago I
talked about this AI Mega structure
problem it's actually a problem in
complex systems because you have
different large language models which
themselves have as much data as the
Library of Congress they were trained on
just massive amounts of data you can
tell that they're highly intelligent and
they can be manipulated we'll be
interacting with each other in ways that
go well beyond our current computational
models and that is why we need
International agreements we need
parameters um with business for what can
be produced and established
methodologies for these elements
interacting in the internet ecosystem
system it is a problem in complex
systems and that's why Congress needs to
give money to establish um institut
studying human machine interaction and
that's actually why I founded a center
called the center for the future mind at
Florida Atlantic University where we
study these from a complex systems
perspective um but that also leads me to
a really interesting point which um
jobst brought up about how
we're never going to obtain AI because
we don't we're not able to emulate the
human brain or model the human brain and
I in your interesting book I was able to
read a few chapters on the way over um I
was super excited to hear that kind of a
discussion but I do
disagree AI is not brain-like that's the
difference so large language models when
they operate they operate using
different algorithms than the brain does
by and large there are some interesting
similarities but there are a lot of
points of difference we don't need
something that perfectly models the
brain to get brain likee activities from
a functional standpoint and that's
spooky too because it basically means
that we could be outmoded in the
workplace and that gets gets into those
issues involving technological
unemployment it is as
if we humans create created something
that can do what we do differently
cheaper and without all the complexity
of the biological brain I'll give you an
example how many of you heard of
alphao so it was that first moment when
we started to say uhoh this stuff could
be working these algorithms are actually
quite intelligent so go is a tricky
game and when Deep Mind was able to
build a go playing
system it excelled by not being brain
likee it didn't operate like the brain
it did nothing that the world's best go
Champions did it followed different
heris in fact it's surprised the
programmers and that's the whole point
of these large language models they are
black boxes they operate differently
than we
do but
notice they don't model the brain
they're nevertheless able to model our
behavior in certain ways and for that
very reason these highly complex systems
are immensely unknown and unknowns at
the level of AI are no fun because
that's the space in which people can
build Mega viruses with large language
models and distribute those um and
that's been a major concern of iarpa for
example um and other organizations in
Washington it's also the level where we
can see very
complex uh behaviors on social media
platforms we can see the amplification
of discontent we can see deep fakes that
cause people to think that in a war zone
they're going to a safe area but they're
not they're actually being fooled by a
malicious actor all kinds of things can
happen and that's why we need a St a
science that actually learns to
understand the nature of machine Minds
so in some consider the affirmative
position even though regulations are
painful right and not the first thing we
should move to when you're talking about
global catastrophic risk you're talking
about a space in which at least in the
short term we may need some guard rails
thank you
just uh 7 and a half minutes you want to
take the podium and do it from there no
I will sit here yeah is the microphone
working good so um let me start with the
following I'm not saying that we
necessarily have to model AI according
to how natural brain works however
because we don't understand how
intelligence works if you want to create
intelligence we have to model the
intelligence of an animal at least but
what we have is not intelligent at all
what we have now are syntactic
algorithms that can basically create
sequences that are similar to sequence
they have already seen in reality so
everything in llm gives you is a
sequence that is similar to sequence
that that it has um of of symbols that
it has had have been fed to it when it
was trained so it has nothing to do with
intelligence but it just replicates
sequences and it can't find any new
solutions to anything but only can
identify regular patterns this has
nothing to do with intellig
we understand I as a mathematician can
tell you that we understand the
mathematics of these of these systems
very well they are in in in the end
functions or operators in the sense um
of um of mathematics of function
analysis we understand very well how
they work in principle we don't
understand the detailed parameterization
of them but we understand what they do
and what they do is that they when we
train them we create huge uh um
distributions um multimodal
distributions that or multi parametric
distributions that reflect the sequence
of the symbols that we encounter in the
training material and that's what they
then can create as output they can't
create new viruses they're completely
uses for this my job is that I'm
research director of a biotech startup
where I use I AI all the time to model
living systems in tumor biology that can
only reproduce patterns that have
already been um found in the data and so
when we use them for tumor biology
research we only use them to unravel
regular patterns we cannot find
irregularities with them and it will
never be possible because they are not
complex systems so what you said is
fundamentally wrong an llm is not a
complex system it is a simple system
what's the difference between a complex
and a simple system a a simple system
doesn't have the seven thermodynamic
properties out of which I listed three
it has all of them that makes the
complex systems be complex are not
present in logic systems and llm is
very has a lot of parameters but it's
still a simple system like all systems
we engineer and therefore it cannot
emulate the properties of a complex
system so it is wrong to say that llm
are complex systems now to the notion of
a mega structure actually when you
connect llms they create only crap and
they degenerate very quickly this has
been shown ma mathematically so when you
take one llm and create and give it
output to another llm and then to
another one and so on they will and
retrain them with the output that they
create then they will degenerate and
create only meaningless uh syntactical
um crap and this is because they are
actually in the training process entropy
is built in right and so what what then
happens is when you retrain the the the
llms with their own material the entropy
kicks in that's also thermodynamical law
and they degenerate so they they don't
have any anything that that makes them
dangerous when they interact on their
own they just become it just creates a
lot of crap and that's already happening
so in the internet now you have a lot of
texts that were created by llm and now
if you come and take these texts and
retrain lmms based on this they were
they generate in the fa same fashion so
it's plainly wrong to say that they are
that they are intelligent the
intelligence definition I have given
which is the best intelligence
definition we have of course requires
Consciousness so there is no
intelligence without Consciousness there
is no will without Consciousness
Consciousness is a precondition so a
slime mold doesn't have real
intelligence it doesn't find a new
solution to to a problem that it has not
encountered only higher animals can do
this birds can do it and mammals can do
it um uh uh humans can do it but most of
the animals are not intelligent in this
sense and neither are are are machines
that are unconscious machines also only
um perform what they've been told to do
so the so-called novel pattern
are novel only in a closed world so we
have to distinguish open world
intelligence with it intelligence that
we have and what what machines do which
is restricted to close situations which
are pre parameterized as soon as you
change any of the dimensions of the of
the coordinate system in which is the
face bace in which such AIS act they
completely fall apart so of course the
GO train go algorithm cannot play chess
and vice versa of course you can create
a meta algorithm that can play many
games but when you change the rule the
rule of one of the games the AI will
fail whereas a human being when you have
a round of round of poker players and
tell them let's change this rule they
can immediately adapt this is real
intelligence machines completely fail
when they have off sample situations
that's because of the third property
that I mentioned the non-erotic
character of human intelligence or
animal intelligence means that that um
anytime new situations can come about
and that these new we can deal with
these new situations machines cannot
they fail when there is a sample that
does not correspond to the distribution
that was used to previously train um the
machine so in the end the whole machine
learning is an illusion machines do not
learn anything but they are only
parameterized to to they are forced to
find regular patterns in distribution
that's also why they fail on um on
questions llm fail on questions that
have not been present in the training
material also interesting is that they
are only traed with one question one
answer one task one solution because if
you would try to to do a dialogue with
three or four um interactions so a b a a
you would have to you have infinitely
many possibilities of training them
because the conversation can go in many
directions infinitively many so
therefore there are only trade for one
question one answer that's why when you
have a longer dialogue with them you can
actually elicit a behavior avior of the
llm that is not trainable and then you
are suddenly exploring the untrained
part of the face space and this is this
is just creating chaos so so therefore
there's no aim there's no intention
there's no will there's no intelligence
at all these are just synthetic machines
the problem we have and why I am of a
different opinion is I'm only I think we
mainly need to regulate weapons of mass
destruction but not because they they
act on their own but because they're
very dangerous as and very powerful the
last point I want to make the whole
Washington and EU agenda to over
regulate AI is only supposed to maintain
the monopolies of the huge corporations
it's not to protect us but it is it is
meant to raise the barriers of Market
entrance and to a to make sure that
Facebook and and x and Google maintain
their Monopoly positions it's just a
monopoly protection game like we know
from many other Industries it had
nothing to do with helping us or saving
us everything in the regulation nothing
is a reculation will protect us it will
only protect the Monopoly games of the
big players thank you very
much uh now we go to the Q&A portion of
the evening and uh you can line up over
there and uh there is a mic I think on
the back balcony we will entertain
questions from the balcony please guys
uh pipe down a little bit guys you have
the opportunity to uh job and Susan to
ask each other questions if you would
like I would like to start guys please
um whatever uh let's Converse at the
party a little bit later uh about the uh
debate I I would like to exercise
moderator's prerogative to start with a
question to you Susan um it has to do
what I I want to quote a couple
sentences from your book interesting
book which I read recommend uh having to
do with what seems to be the idea of
Consciousness in a machine you're right
a clever machine could bypass safeguards
such as kill switches and could
potentially pose an existential threat
to biological life the control problem
is a serious problem Perhaps it is even
insurmountable uh similarly you wrote
with self-improvement algorithms and
with rapid computations an AI machine
could quickly discover ways to become
vastly smarter than us becoming a Super
intelligence that is an AI that
outthinks Us in every domain because it
is super intelligent we probably can't
control it it could in principle render
us
extinct now with those passages you see
seem to be talking about a machine with
a will and a
Consciousness am I correct in so
interpreting you in that
way great question and it connects
nicely up to the debate um no
so everything you just quoted can happen
in absence of the machine having any
kind of felt quality of experience so
that's what Consciousness is it's that
felt quality of experience so when you
uh smell an espresso or sit in your
chair you know you feel a whole range of
different things that's what it is for
you to be a conscious being you're
conscious even when you're asleep when
you're
dreaming AI may not be conscious I mean
that's several chapters in the book it's
a very complicated
issue the anthropomorphization of AI in
this Terminator like fashion makes us
think that these chat Bots or in the
more far-fetched futuristic case of
super intelligence which I my own
affirmative case didn't hang on we think
it must be conscious but that's not
that's not the case the other thing is
the issue of free will it comes up a lot
and you mentioned it um I don't think
that um we even need to get into that
debate as a philosopher I'm happy to
right I mean buy me a drink and I'll
tell you all about free will but I don't
even think humans have it and a lot of
philosophers don't there are various
stances you can take on the issue right
but something can still be dangerous in
absence of having this ability to break
free of the laws and somehow
magically do what the laws didn't
dictate the laws of nature the laws of
physics or its program whatever super
intelligence could be as dangerous as
those passages and I think it is
something we need to worry about in the
future for the next few years my concern
is more with emergent chatbot
interactions in the AI ecosystem both of
us are worried about lethal autonomous
weapons I'm worried about the biological
case right um but anyway I'll get to the
next question did I answer your question
okay well you said that you don't think
that even though it says that it could
potentially it it could bypass
safeguards such as kill switches it uh
we probably can't control it it seems as
though it has a will let's not use the
word Consciousness it seems as though it
has a will of its own and is beyond our
control because it has a will of its own
I'm
misinterpreting um no it's not that it
would have a will of its own it has a
will of its own no no um it has so I was
referring to Nick bostrom's influential
book called Super intelligence and the
point was that there were recursive
self-improving algorithms so
that so um so basically the machine
having these recursive self-improving
algorithms can determine how to best
improve
itself and make newer versions of itself
continually upgrading if you will and
ultimately no longer be aligned with
human interests it's okay just JS let it
finish and you'll get a s response uh
it's programming isn't mathematical
nonsense and either is
recursion so you know I I don't see that
point at all okay uh Jeffs do you want
to comment on the question and answer
there is so there is no self-improvement
possible in in machines so what machines
can do they can only
um compute the algorithm that was
defined before and this algorithm has
some um uh possibilities to change its
configuration but that is not
self-improvement so the problem is that
if we of course if we Define
intelligence in a way uh with a with a
pseudo definition then we can call
machines intelligent but that's saying
I'm flying right but I was only jumping
up and down so I I'm I'm basically
changing the definition of flying to
claim that I'm flying but basically
that's what you're doing so you are you
are just um basically not um defining
intelligence properly so that you can
say that machines can be intelligent or
self-improved but it's very clear that
the definitions of intelligence given by
the by Nick Bostrom and the AGI
Community are have nothing to do with
intelligence and they are basically very
simple pseudo definitions of
intelligence so that they're set up so
that they can say who R we fulfill them
and now we can claim that we are
intelligent but if if you take any
machine and put it into a situation that
it has not seen before it will always
fail and and there are very very many
reasons for this but in the end that
means that machines are not intelligent
llms are not intelligent and they can't
um they can't create anything new uh
yeah you guys can ask each other a
question at any point but we uh have a
great deal of Interest I guess from the
audience so let's start taking audience
questions please ask a question as a
question no need to identify yourself my
question is about regulation it it seems
to me that this is a little similar to
nuclear energy can be used for good can
be used for terrible and um governments
do regulate it and kind of based on that
regulation there are many more bombs
than there are power plants and so I'm
wondering and then when the bombs are
used it's people that don't have them
are the ones that get killed the
civilians so I'm wondering to what
degree you think this should be
regulated is is there a line um I guess
question is rested jobs and then Susan
you'll comment jobs okay so I think that
the only regulation we need is the type
of Regulation that we have for Atomic
biological and chemical bombs and this
is to prevent terrible types of warfare
where Millions get killed and maimed in
very short periods and not because the
systems are intelligent but because the
algorithms make them very effective in
Mass killing right so it's not that the
computer suddenly can decide I'm going
to kill anyone but it's just like a very
good tool to kill many people and I
think what we in World War I we
experienced that nothing was regulated
then Millions got killed and maimed
terribly with chemical weapons and then
they were regulated and that was a good
thing that's the regulation I'm asking
for and there's market failure here
right so we need the M when there's a
massive market failure we need
regulation that's the regulation I'm
mainly asking for the other regulations
Susan is asking for I think are there
only to protect monopolies of the
incumbents who have the big llms today
on the big the big systems and they
invested billions in them and now they
want to basically protect their
investment from competition from small
companies and this is regulation I'm up
against but I'm in favor of the
regulating mass destruction weapons any
comments
Susan uh I'm so confused because I do
not believe we should protect monop and
that those should be the only
regulations um so um actually I think a
lot of people in Washington Republicans
Democrats I mean I was really thrilled
to see Biden's AI initiative his
directorate and it actually made a good
deal of effort to protect small
businesses and to try to
bring uh the expense of using large
language models down for universities
and for businesses um and it did not
endorse licensing and um which is
something the Monopoly the big Tech
wanted so I mean I you know I agreed
with the content
of the directorate and do not want to
protect big Tech monopolies now where
what is appropriate regulation um real
quick I I do think that we need to have
some regulation on deep fakes
watermarking for example I don't think
that um we should have deep fakes
especially during elections or during
um during crisis uh like for example we
shouldn't allow um fake news about safe
zones like in Gaza say um I also think
that we need to regulate lethal
autonomous weapons and have clear
standards and have international
standards on the AI
ecosystem so that our AI Services
throughout the world interact properly
so we need to work with China right um
okay yeah next
question so if I understood yops
correctly your thesis is that artificial
intelligence requires Consciousness
because intelligence requires
Consciousness as a necessary condition
for intelligence to exist since we have
no such systems just syntactical
manipulation machines we have no AI in
that strict sense thus far um if that
understanding of your position is
correct then my question for Susan is if
AI is construed as requiring
Consciousness in the way that he uh laid
it out do you still think that AI in the
future constitutes a threat to the
survival of humanity and needs to be
regulated now all I guess we'll let Jeff
go first cuz you asked him first Jobs go
first I mean let let's for the sake of
the argument imagine that there could be
intelligence without
Consciousness that is not possible
because Consciousness is the
precondition for
perception and Consciousness is the
answer of of evolution to to comp
complex perception patterns and
Consciousness evolved in evolution to
deal with with with this High perception
load of higher organisms and and then we
have active perception which we don't
understand which which we cannot model
mathematically either it's called um
little more to the mic the mic yeah it's
called and it's it and it's very
complicated it's interaction of the
sensory organs with the with the motor
capabilities of our eyes and our brain
and our Limbs and so on and and this
leads then to to our ability to react to
new to novel situations but we need the
the active per perception and without
Consciousness we don't have active
perceptions machines have zero active
perception that's why robotics is stuck
in the 70s we have had almost no real
progress in robotics I mean very little
progress and that's because we can't
mathematically model active perception
and and for this to do it I think we
also need Consciousness so yes we are
stuck because so do do do you seem to be
saying that the questioner gave a fair
summary of your views of Consciousness
does that AFF first it was a bit
shortening it but in in in principle yes
was it a fair summary yeah yes it was a
fair summary I didn't hear what you said
was it a fair summary of of your views
yes yes okay yeah go ahead yeah thanks I
agree exactly and I would also add that
um it does not fall out of the
definition of intelligence from Le and
Hunter for AI enthusiasts they don't
talk about Consciousness in their
definition but that's just a side point
but I completely agree thank you for
that summary um if I may if I may say
something about the leata definition the
leata definition is a utilitarian
definition of intelligence was said
which says that you have intelligence if
you maximize a utility function and this
is this is historically grounded in in
British
utilitarianism and mathematically it is
advantageous because it is a definition
of intelligence that can be fulfilled
with Calculus so they've basically
thought of a definition that they can
fulfill anyhow now that's very nice you
know so I can I can actually make a
photo of myself and say to be the most
beautiful man in the world you have to
look like this that's what they're
basically doing but it's cheating it
what this function has nothing to do
whatsoever with intelligence it's it's
just a utility function that they then
can minimize and then they Shout at the
new in their AGI paper Journal toay
we've we've won but but but that's just
pathetic
really
question I have a question about the the
regulation of deep fakes in particular
little more to the mic little regulation
closer to the mic second yeah regulation
of what of deep fakes during elections
which is one of the sort of Doomsday
issues you pointed out
how as a practical matter when trillions
of pieces of content are posted to the
internet every day could you possibly
flag you know even a portion of them and
then given that we have a First
Amendment right to publish what we want
how is a legal matter for the government
in particular impose that kind of
Regulation uh I guess the questions to
Susan that's a really good question so
this is all currently unclear uh in the
United States uh the Biden AI initiative
just came out a few weeks ago and I
believe that they're giving the
responsibility for that Arena to the FTC
we don't know the implementation
and we need also to get
Congress uh to
agree how how do people feel about that
is that going to happen um but that's
where things are at right now with that
issue um and I think you raised a super
important point right so watermarking is
a proposal and there are a lot of people
actually at the programming level
working on water marking and the uh
large AI companies have voluntarily
offered to begin doing that um but I do
worry that people will become so
inundated with visible watermarks on all
of their media content that they'll
start
ignoring the watermarks and just become
neutral and that's why I actually if you
ask me um it I think an outright ban 6
weeks before elections for elections and
during involving War zones I think it
would be appropriate to just ban deep
fake content and to regulate so that the
AI companies can't just let it slip
through the cracks I mean Facebook just
hired its whole ethics board you know
unless you force them to be careful
about these issues they're not going to
be careful uh you both got a chance to
come and other answers so Jobs go ahead
yeah I I would like to to actually
answer your question technically so
technically it's possible to do that by
training models that detect regularities
that are in deep fakes that are not in
real movies so it's possible to train
adversarial AI that can basically detect
a a deep fake which a human can't detect
so this is technically feasible now what
is the problem with this so the problem
I see is that the danger doesn't come
from private actors or terrorists
there's also some danger and we could
certainly design algorithms that find
these deep fakes issued by private
actors or terrorists but I'm more
worried about deep fakes from the state
you know we have now a situation where
we have so much in the west so much
chinese-like propaganda created by the
very Regulators we are supposed to trust
and I don't want to go into examples I
think those who can't think of the
examples themselves are blind but we
have a real big bad situation now that
the state itself is creating propaganda
and we saw it actually in the Twitter
files right that were unraveled by when
musk took over Twitter so we we we saw
that the state actually was asking big
tech companies to censor and do
propaganda so that's where I see the
danger now I don't have any hope that
those who actually ordered this kind of
censorship and manipulation to be done
will actually do a benevolent
regulation uh next
question thanks for a great debate uh um
conversation I should call it in the
list of dangers um I wonder what you
think pull the mic up a little bit J in
the list of dangers I wonder what
application of AI to um finance and
investing and how it might affect the
market for good or for bad you have any
comments on either your question is
about investment opportunities markets
how is this going to affect free markets
okay how is this going to affect free
markets okay um I'm not sure that it
relates to the survival of humanity but
since we're very free
market we'll entertain the question and
you're an entrepreneur Joe so you
probably have a lot of answers about the
German uh free market yeah so so um it's
very interesting um you know that uh I'm
not a haakan although I like some of his
of his thinking but what you really got
right is that imposs that is impossible
to mathematically beat the market and
that's possible because the market that
that you couldn't see yet but the market
is a complex system made of many complex
systems interacting and therefore you
cannot create Market beating algorithms
so what happens when you put AI systems
into as trading algorithms they can only
do very short-term trading but but mid
to long-term trading they can't because
they cannot integrate and model the
trends and even humans can't do it right
and that's why you can get caught in
markets why you can lose money in
markets so so the usage of AI in trade
and markets won't won't change the
nature of markets and neither will it be
possible to finally um so to speak
create um a communist PL economy using
AI because because uh because for the
reasons that lud fromes showed you
cannot plan an economy and and and this
won't change with AI because the AI
systems are only simple systems and the
market is a complex system and so
therefore um AI um Engineers won't
become Ultra Rich neither will AI
algorithms beat the market did you want
to come in
Susan yeah I
mean economic modeling has been around
for decades I was an economics major um
and you know the big trading houses used
these models all the time and the point
here is that these models can simplify
complex systems and they're better or
worse ones not that there can't be
models that's just an a side two
contexts in which I think regulation
wouldn't be unreasonable one um we need
some regulation to prevent flash
crashes second Ubi which is something
that fredman himself endorsed so that
might be two
situations uh in the future in which we
may need regulations for the financial
markets next
question have to bend down little uh yes
uh I would say the debate could be part
of a larger series on on Creative
destruction where every so and so a new
technology occurs
displacing old Industries and old jobs
creating new ones and new winners I'm
curious and this this is for both
participants do you feel there's ever
been an optimal level of Technology For
Humanity or are we just subject to
Thomas Soul's conclusion on
tradeoffs has there ever been an optimal
level of Technology For
Humanity Okay who wants to take that
difficult
question no I don't think there has um I
love your point and um I
just I think that um the jury's out
about whether the anticipated
technological
unemployment that will likely ensue in
the white collar Arena due to chatbots
and other AI technologies will lead to a
situation in which retraining alone will
be sufficient or if it will be the case
that there will be longstanding
unemployment in which humans are
permanently displaced that's the
question um I think the more doomsday
scenario if you will is a scenario
that's being entertained a lot right now
in Washington on both sides of the aisle
but I want to say on the bright side how
does a 3-day Work Week sound how does an
8-week vacation sound I mean I think
there are really exciting ways that we
can respond to these challenges um jffs
Coming yeah so first I'd like to answer
your question then comment on the White
Collar um uh scenario so technology is
humans replacement for the lack of
instinct says the great philosopher
Arnold G
who was one of the best 20th century
philosophers a bit forgotten now but I
can recommend him to everyone here he's
written the book man his place in the
world it's a great book and there he
says that because we don't have
instincts anymore the way animals have
we need technology to create our own our
own special World in which we can
survive optimally and I think that that
this drive of humans to create
technology since we mastered fire and
and invented the first tools is is never
ending and it just depends on our ethos
whether we use technology you are
benefit or not so I look forward to
nuclear fusion and many great
technologies that will happen I am also
total proponent of using genetic
engineering when it can be safely done
so I'm a real technology freak I love
technology I've always been in
technology all my professional life and
I think it can never there can never be
enough the question is to use it in the
way that it benefits mankind but I think
it it will always continue will get more
and more now to your point about white
collar job displacement I've been
working in AI uh uh optimization of jobs
in the insurance and banking industry
for more than 10 years and um the effect
that we can get from the models is uh 5%
rationalization at most that's because
most of the activities that human beings
white color workers engage in are so
complex that the llms are completely
hopelessly unable to model them if you
look at the llm based startups that got
started between last fall and now um 99%
of them failed there's a huge bubble
that is bursting because the llms are
inefficient to create reliable results
they invent nonsense they they they they
they are
unreliable they they make too much
mistakes on the cognitive side they
misclassify objects all the time that
the misclassification rates of objects
in visual AI is 1 to 2% humans have a
drivers have a one in 10 million
misclassification rate if they are not
stoned or drunk you know and and so and
so machines have 1 to 2% massification
rate I mean come on that's that's just
pathetic to believe that they can
significantly reduce work effort it's 5%
so it's really it's a it's a significant
increase in productivity economically if
you have 5% L cost that's great but it
doesn't mean that you know we we have a
huge employment problem the employment
problem comes from competition with
China competition with China okay that's
a different issue uh next
question what I don't know understand
about this debate is what makes you
think that this regulation you're
talking about can possibly work let
alone not have adverse consequences that
are far worse than the regulation itself
I mean I I I could give many many
examples of that but just as one miss
Schneider you're talking about well
Federal Regulation of this or Federal
Federal Regulation of that they don't
regulate China they don't regulate
Russia so if the federal government says
United States you can't do this and that
well well China will do it Russia will
do it um how
about um well you you mentioned the UN
the UN could do the un can't effectively
regulate anything and even Mr lraber you
you uh talked about well that if there
should be regulation of one thing it
should be like Atomic weapons well the
Russians Atomic weapons aren't regulated
today and the un can't effectively do so
what makes you think this could possibly
work that's my question all right uh
yeah
maybe J job should take that first and
then Susan jobs so just on Weapons of
Mass destructions there has been a very
effective effort to prevent the usage of
weapons of mass destruction with
chemical and biological weapons after
World War one so in World War II they
were not used though both the Germans
and the Allies had them they were not
used and there was also a very efficient
after Hiroshima and nagazaki attempt to
prevent the usage of atomic bombs uh
against civilians and so there can be
because humans are not only bad you know
there can be even International
agreements on the usage of such weapons
this is all I'm asking for this is what
I think I think what will happen is that
they will not regulate it and there will
be a very obvious usage of a is wmd in
the future with millions of killed and
then we will learn and agree
internationally to not do this again
that's what I see happening and that's
all I'm asking for I would like to not
see 10 or 20 or $50 million die before
we get this kind of international
agreement I think that's all I'm asking
for all right we veed into wmds U but
did you have any comment
Susan yeah I think a concern for China
is actually what's behind a lot of the
AI regulations so China uh
recently has a very
centralized group of
regulations that they released on AI
model models and AI developments and the
US felt that they needed to step up to
the plate and have a regulatory
structure because they could uh fall
prey to
disadvantage um there's been a lot of
papers in this in say Foreign Affairs
for example I'm just saying what the
situation is um there's also been a
concern that um large language models
released by China would be used against
us for um the purpose of um
disinformation uh so I think the concern
actually uh about China is one of the
things behind the current regulations
yeah next question my question is for
jobs so you were talking about like two
different kinds of tiers of AI one of
which you said was not possible like a
conscious Ai and the other one that we
we see like right now so how does
government regulation not solve for like
the capacity for harm that people can
have with the AI that we have right now
does that make sense uh I'm not certain
but I try to answer so first of all what
we have is not AI what we have are is
Applied Mathematics that can be used to
to identify and um and leverage regular
patterns in data and and that that will
that can be abused in many ways right
and I don't think that um
that we need what we need is actually
certification of products right and so
we have certification of products in
many many domains in food in Pharma I
mean in in in technology every airplane
gets certified if actually the
certification in airpl is so tough if
you're at the airport in your city in
the plane there's a technical test and
if one of the tests fails the airplane
is not allowed to to to to to depart and
so on so what we need is technology
certification as we have it in many
other domains and that that will solve
most of the problem so that's what we
need and and the regulation in the sense
of of um of heavy-handed um surveillance
will not solve the problems but what we
need is it's just a technology like all
the other Technologies we have and we
have to deal with it in a normal way you
know C certificate system where the
companies that makes the systems need to
prepare c c certificate then basically
the the state just looks at the C
certificate whether it's complete and
then it's it's it's going to production
and what this does is actually that it
defines a range of tests that the system
needs to fulfill and if it can fulfill
the test it's safe and yes we have there
will be hackers and people who try to
abuse it like what Susan said and then
we build defense systems against this
and these defense systems will also be
certified it's just as it has always
been with technology you know even the
printing of books is dangerous uh you
want to comment Susan or no yeah okay uh
next
question so uh I may have missed
something but I think when you both use
the term artificial intelligence you're
talking about very different things
actually so I was asking I would ask
each one of you if possible to just give
a simple definition or complex
definition but a definition what do you
mean by artificial intelligence what do
you mean by artificial intelligence
Susan take it
away algorithms that manipulate their
environment predict future States so I
have a more expansive definition I
believe than my
opponent so I think that St definition
is is uh is empty because they
algorithms can't manipulate the
environment in the way she believes and
they can't predict the future but what
they but my definition is artificial
intelligence are algorithms that can
identify regular patterns in data and
can either be used to show these
regularities or to automate regularities
like you you know for example quality
control in in industrial plants or in in
in a power plant and this is where it
can be used whenever you have
regularities then they are also
predictive because of the regularity as
soon as you have no regularity they fail
and that is that's why the the name
artificial intelligence is a Mis Noma
it's just Applied Mathematics and
artificial intelligence is a propaganda
term uh like you know uh the the the
Soviet Union propaganda term communism
will win because it's true
propaganda term okay uh thank you for
the question and uh next uh
question hi I have a technical question
um you had said that there are some
limitations with respect to modeling
intelligence due to for example
properties of thermodynamics so I'm
wondering if that limitation could be
overcome for example by collecting data
from the natural environment yes so this
is a this is a very very important
question thank you very much this is
what I I I mean it was very complicated
in my talk I tried to explain this
non-erotic property of natural systems
with the waves so when you measure
natural phenomena which are non-erotic
you never can sample enough data to
predict their behavior because every
time you make a measurement the micro
states are different so so when I shake
this bottle of water what's happening in
the in the turbulence is not not
repetitive and and and so because of
this by measuring at the micro States I
can't predict the future state and
therefore the whole approach of AI that
is being used that is working by
sampling from the natural environment
fails on complex systems this is very
hard to understand but it means that you
can measure as long as you want you can
put infinitive amounts of text into the
llms they will only reproduce regular
patterns but the whole irregularity that
that is so obvious in this discussion
for example so much unpredicted happen
in the discussion is not cannot be
captured and that's the beauty in the
end of our of our natural environment um
we're running out of time so uh you
could have to ask the question and maybe
it'll comment it in the summaries uh so
ask the question
please so this is the strangest Soho
forum debate I've heard because it seems
like both people are arguing for the
affirmative am I wrong about that
because it seems to me that that you're
saying that what we commonly call
artificial intelligence must be
regulated you're just simply saying that
there it's a misnomer to call let me
remind you that the resolution reads
it's a threat to the survival of
humanity that the that must be addressed
by government it's not a matter of
whether it's regulated or not to clarify
the resolution survival of humanity must
be addressed by government not whether
other aspects should be regulated you
see those words survival of humanity is
being threatened yeah but it does seem
like he's conceited that point
no okay well please argue why you
haven't considered the point the debate
is the debate is over the survival of
humanity being autonomous weapons Point
seems like a concession to me I don't
think they are autonomous weapons are no
autonomous weapons guys guys again I
only want to say that the words survival
of humanity is in the resolution you
both agreed to it so it's not a matter
of whether it should be regulated it's a
matter of whether it's threat to the
survival of humanity should be addressed
by government take it away both you guys
in your summaries and please address the
resolution as stated the affirmative
goes first in the in the summary Susan
you can take the podium or you can do it
from your chair either one all the I had
a double espresso shot at the beginning
of this and it wore off so now you'll
see me
plummet so how much time do I have five
minutes oh okay well I'll go quicker
than that um so to the point that just
arose I don't know if it's worthwhile to
get caught up in defining stuff right I
think that we realize that he did
Express a concern about Warfare about
the robotization of warfare and about
autonomous weapons now maybe he's going
to change definition but the point here
is that that is a threat that is
generally regarded as a threat to the
survival of maybe not all of humanity
but many in humanity and he concedes
that that needs regulation so that is a
concession to the affirmative he also
seems friendly to regulations in general
in certain context and he expressed some
really great points and I want to thank
my opponent because I am I share his
deep worry about this state using the
tools of these large language models
against us and I think that's something
we need to be very careful about I also
think though that what we do need and
this is a regulatory issue in the sense
that funding Federal funding through
Congress to universities to study the
issue is what we need we need a science
of machine human
interaction through you know centers
like my own the center for the future
mind sorry couldn't resist but other
organizations as well to study the
future and you know I'm actually I have
a piece in Nautilus on this very issue
of the epistemology of these chat Bots I
think the whole issue is quite
horrifying um I think a lot of really
important issues have come up in this
debate um how to define different issues
such as intelligence and complex system
how to
distinguish the dangers that intelligent
algorithms bring to the table
independent of their Consciousness or
free will I'm really glad that we've
been able to dissociate those issues and
see that one can be concerned about the
AI
systems without thinking of a Terminator
you killer robot
scenario I'm just worried merely about
the complex interaction of AI services
in the internet ecosystem because
actually this is a matter of being
studied in complex systems I have a
center that studies this this has to do
with variables and models that are
incredibly hard to iron out there's
something called algorithmic Inc
incompressibility there's a whole range
of issues akin to what we see in
economics that universities and other
institutes will have to study in order
to make this a safer future but I do
think we have to
entertain
regulations um for in particular the
issue of autonomy what is it there needs
to be a common understanding ing of when
autonomous weapons and if autonomous
weapons in the context of AI should be
utilized these are very serious issues
so I've had the opportunity to debate um
people who Advocate complete abolition
of autonomous
weapons sadly there's dangers that we
face right now concerning Hypersonic
missiles that will require the use of AI
otherwise we won't won't as humans be
able to perceive threats um and the
question becomes well what level you
know at what point do we draw the line
and there it's urgent that the
military and the defense structures in
general have clearcut guidelines about
what to follow and that they're
International regulations otherwise
we're all dead sorry but I mean these
situations have only grown due to the
blackbox phenomena of these large
language models you've probably all
interacted with GPT 4 or three when it's
hallucinated or when it's behaved in
very erratic ways remember the famous
case in the New York Times involving
Sydney we certainly need to think hard
about whether to use any of these
systems in the context of warfare and
have clear regulations thank
you um so I would like to make clear
that I don't think that artificial
intelligence poses a threat to the
survival of humanity but that Humanity
poses a threat to the survival of
humanity and and g andas a German
philosopher I don't like him so much he
wrote a book he was a pupil of Haider
whom I hate and he he wrote he he wrote
a book about the Antiquity of man when
the a bomb was developed in the' 40s and
he said the a bomb Has Changed History
because now Humanity can erase itself
and it's not an a bomb somewhere that
erases us but we would erase ourselves
by by by launching many a bombs and in
that sense AI is dangerous because but
not it's not autonomous autonomy is
actually philosophically the root of our
dignity and of the natural law
philosophically speaking so it it's a
total misn Nora to call an algorithm
autonomous because it doesn't have
dignity it doesn't the natural law
doesn't apply to it it's just technology
and so and so the so-called autonomous
weapon systems are not autonomous they
are programmed to perform certain
killing acts to make this clear very
sophisticated um systems have been used
in the Ukraine warp on both sides in
terms of sensors so be which prevented
actually any of the sites of moving in
secret so that's why moving units were
destroyed so rapidly and why artillery
was so important in this War and why
Russia is unfortunately winning because
they have more artillery because because
but the on the AI side the the sides
were equal but the next generation of AI
will be swarms of flying um you know um
units that can kill approaching like
lering units that can kill approaching
um enemies uh indiscriminately and and
and very rapidly and there's actually no
defense against this and such such AI
system are not autonomous but they are
programmed to kill very effectively and
like you know like ABC bomb ABC weapons
and that's what that's why what I want
to regulate but I don't think that ice
threatens Mankind in any other way than
any other technology it's it's mankind
which is dangerous for mankind man is
killing man using tools and it can be a
hammer it can be a screwdriver or it can
be an atomic bomb it doesn't matter it's
always a human being that uses the
technology to kill other human beings
and so my point is not that saying that
AI threatens mankind implies that AI is
somehow an actor that is the basic
mistake that is now made in Washington
in Brussels everywhere the politicians
and also many of my colleagues don't
understand that AI is a misn noral that
there's nothing intelligent here that
it's not actually a subject that can act
on its own but they all the time also
when you say oh the llms are so
dangerous where they will communicate
about among each other no it they create
only it they they actually they
can do nothing productive they just it's
it's mathematically shown that they if
they communicate among themselves it's
just entropy being created and it it's
actually if you understand function
analysis you know why this is happening
because basically the they only take the
regular pattern out of the language and
create new regular patterns and then out
of this again a subset will be taken so
that there is a downward spiral of
finding ever more primitive regularities
that's all they do there's nothing more
about it
and and so so therefore my I'm clearly
the negative because I think there is no
threat from a i there's only threat from
man against man and and so when we talk
about about regulation we have to talk
about regulating how man uses technology
and and and some of you said that this
mostly failed and yes that's true but
but but I think with weapons of mass
destruction we have made good experience
in the 20th century that we've used them
much less than we could could have and
that's encouraging and that's all I'm
asking for all the rest is not so much
about regulation but about the typical
the way that you have to use technology
you have to have certification and you
have of course to be very careful about
and to to know how you can be attacked
with technology right so when the when
the book was invented the printing press
the Protestants attacked the Catholics
by printing Flyers you know thousands of
Fes and it was a huge attack it actually
took away a lot of power of the Catholic
princes and created a new whole set of
protestant princes like who then became
super successful like Prussia Saxony who
became Protestants and that that led to
huge Wars in in Europe you know so so
the Reformation is a very good example
for of Technology uses and now we just
face a similar thing llms are just like
the leaflets in the reformation and we
have to be careful what our enemies can
do with them and then also have counter
measures like the Catholics than they
had you know uh um the Jesuits so we
need basically llm Jesuit it you know
and and and that's all it's just a
natural way of dealing with technology
thank you very
much uh Jane uh please open the final
voting artificial intelligence poses a
threat to the survival of humanity that
must be actively addressed by government
please uh vote yes no or undecided on
the resolution I have in my hand the so
form Tootsie Roll that will be thrown at
the winner of the debate whoever moves
the vote in his or her favor uh
meanwhile uh I do want to encourage you
to come to our Afterparty two blocks up
town follow me again not hard to find 55
great Jones Street which is actually
third Third Street uh and just two
blocks up town uh both our Debaters are
invited there for the food and the drink
they're both very approachable you have
probably far more to learn from each of
them uh if you have questions you would
like to put to them at our
Afterparty uh meanwhile we are also
launching a fundraising Drive shortly
you will see a 13-minute video of me
imploring you for more money and
explaining to you what we can do with it
we spend very little on ourselves it all
goes upfront to devoting to uh to to
these debates that we hold every month
of the year a 13-minute video you can
look forward to if you go into the
Donate link I believe it will be posted
in a couple of days
meanwhile uh our next debate will be in
December well before Christmas it won't
conflict with Hanukkah it will be Sunday
afternoon a mattin at 3 P.M December
17th
2023 in that case the resolution will
read the making of national internet
policy was hindered rather than helped
by the July 4th Federal Court ruling
that restricted the Biden
administration's Communications with
social media platforms defending the
resolution will be Kate clonic associate
professor at St John's University law
school opposing the resolution will be
Jay
bataria a professor of medicine at
Stanford University and as many of you
know he was one of the main plaintiffs
in that July 4th Federal Court ruling
tickets are onale sale December for that
December 17th Sunday afternoon at 300
p.m. debate uh on Monday January 29th uh
that will be our next debate uh the
resolution will read government must
play a role in fostering scientific and
technological progress by funding basic
research uh defending the resolution
will be Tony Mills senior fellow at the
American Enterprise Institute opposing
the resolution uh will be Terrence
Keeley author of the economic laws of
scientific
research Monday February 26th we will uh
uh the resolution will read the root
cause of the Israeli Palestinian
conflict is the Palestinians rejection
of Israel's right to exist
the affirmative will be defended by Eli
Lake American journalist the negative
will be taken by Jeremy Hammond author
of obstacle to peace the US role in the
Israeli Palestinian conflict that
particular debate will not be held here
it will be held at the so Playhouse a
few uh blocks to the west of us we do
have a downstairs there for our
afterparty uh that's February 26 about
the Israeli Palestinian conflict Jane
how are we doing on the voting I think
Jane is coming to me with the final
results drum roll please
yeah all right the uh the yes vote uh
began with
23% and it ended with 26% it picked up
3.2 percentage points that's the number
to beat the no vote began with 44% it
went to 62% it it uh therefore picked up
17.9 percentage points the no vote wins
the debate
congratulations and come to the after
party congratulations to you both and
thank you uh Afterparty at uh 55 great
Jones Street follow me both Debaters
will be there thanks again
congratulations